the phrase banality of evil was coined
by political theorist Hannah arand in
her work ikman in Jerusalem to describe
the startling ordinariness of Adolf ikan
a key architect of the Holocaust arin's
observation during Aikman's trial in
1961 LED here to conclude that evil
Deeds can be committed on a grand scale
not only by sociopaths or fanatics but
also by ordinary individuals individuals
who accept the ideologies of their state
without question Ing and participate in
any ongoing Injustice with the energy of
a good bureaucrat to begin with it is
crucial to revisit aren's portrayal of
ikman far from the Monstrous figure one
would expect ikman appeared to arand as
a bland bureaucrat a cog in the Nazi
machine who coordinated the logistics of
genocide with the same Detachment with
which one might organize a simple
business task the reason we failed to
understand evil is because we failed to
understand that evil can manifest
through ordinary individuals when they
ignore personal moral judgment in favor
of a collective ideology or authority
evil comes from a failure to think it
defies thought for as soon as thought
tries to engage itself with evil and
examine the premises and principles from
which it originates it is frustrated
because it finds nothing there that is
the banality of evil the banality of
evil does not suggest that evil acts are
mundane or that they lack seriousness
rather it points to the terrifying
normality of the individuals who
perpetrate them the unassuming neighbor
the diligent bureaucrat the obedient
Soldier it's the chilling recognition
that Those who commit acts of evil
aren't always Twisted villains from the
pages of a dark fairy tale but rather
everyday people who are often doing what
they perceive to be just another day's
work arin's thesis emerged in a post-war
World Wrestling with the atrocities of
the Holocaust attempting to comprehend
how a civilized society could
orchestrate such systematic horror yet
your insights are enduring as we
navigate a modern society still scarred
with the evils of War genocide systemic
racism environmental destruction and
Corruption to understand why evil
persists we must examine the fabric of
our social and political structures in
many cases people involved in evil acts
do not perceive the themselves as agents
of wrongdoing but are small cogs in a
vast machine exempt from personal
responsibility consider the modern
workplace where individuals may follow
orders or company protocols without
questioning the morality of their
actions a financial advisor might sell a
retirement fund without disclosing its
high risks because it is part of a
Target to meet or a corporate employee
might ignore environmental policies to
cut costs and Maxim imiz profits driven
by a culture that rewards such outcomes
the moral implications of these
decisions are often obfuscated by jargon
complex systems and a chain of command
that dilutes individual accountability
furthermore the digital age has
introduced new modes of being that allow
the banality of evil to persist with the
anonymity afforded by the internet
individuals can participate in or be
complicit in harmful actions without the
immediate recognition of their
consequences cyber bullying the spread
of misinformation and the invasion of
privacy through data mining are just a
few examples of how ordinary individuals
can become part of cycles of harm
despite an increasing awareness of
Social injustices and the mechanisms
that perpetuate them there remains a
significant gap between knowledge and
action in many instances societies
failed to challenge or dismantle the
structures that allow evil to thrive
from from inadequate Justice systems to
corporate impunity from international
relations that turn a blind eye to
atrocities to economic systems that
prioritize profit over people the
institutionalization of such behaviors
makes the perpetuation of evil all too
easy the Allure of Conformity also plays
a crucial role aen pointed out how akan
was not a psychopath or a sociopath but
rather alarmingly normal his actions
were in line with a broader societal
accept of hateful Behavior today this
pressure to conform can be seen in the
widespread reluctance to challenge norms
and ideologies for fear of exclusion the
desire to belong and to be accepted can
often override the moral compass leading
individuals to partake in or ignore the
evils occurring in their own communities
and Beyond actions are justified by the
pressing need to adhere to schedules to
follow orders to do what is expected
just because it is expected this
conforming where questions are left
unasked is precisely where evil nests
and evolves unnoticed until its
consequences emerge in a stark often
irreversible way the role of Education
or the lack thereof is significant in
understanding the continuation of these
patterns critical thinking and moral
philosophy are not the most dominant
part of our Educational Systems without
the tools to question to evaluate and to
dissect information individuals are more
susceptible to falling into the roles
prescribed to them by an ethically blind
Society arent herself was a proponent of
the kind of thinking that stops and
interrogates that pulls apart the status
quo to examine the threads of morality
within but in societies where education
is a privilege rather than a right where
it is instrumental rather than
transformative the capacity to cultivate
this mode of thought is lost media Wills
enormous power in shaping perceptions
and consequently actions in a
journalistic landscape that often values
sensationalism over in-depth analysis
The Narrative of evil is sensationalized
and othered framed as the act of
radicals and Outsiders rather than a
knowledged as the possible outcome of
everyday decisions and systems this
externalization of evil serves to
absolve the collective responsibility
perpetuating the myth that evil is
always something outside of us rather
than a potential component of the fabric
of normal life the modern era has seen
the emergence of new forms of propaganda
and the manipulation of truth that make
the ability to judge good and evil more
challenging in a world of fake news
alternative facts and eoch Chambers of
ideology moral judgment is increasingly
difficult what is evil and what is not
can be obfuscated by the noise of
conflicting narratives and making
inaction or the wrong action part of The
New Normal the economy too has its own
Tales of banality to tell the Relentless
pursuit of economic growth often
Sidelines ethical concerns from the
exploitation of Labor to the
manipulation of financial markets the
normalization of a profit at any cost
mentality provides fertile ground for
evil to Prevail as Arin has shown us
evil may not necessarily result from
deliberate malevolence but also Sprout
from indifference and the prioritization
of One's Own immediate benefit over the
well-being of others this touches upon
another aspect of the human condition
that arent has illuminated the
paralyzing effect of fear whether it is
the fear of poverty of social exclusion
or of existential threats fear can make
the adherence to and perpetuation of
harmful Norms seem like the only viable
option in its banal form evil compels
individuals to make choices that while
seemingly harmless or necessary at the
time are complicit in larger patterns of
harm but there is still hope awareness
of the phenomenon is the first step
towards combating it when we recognize
our capacity for evil only then can we
also recognize our capacity for good
activism and social movements around the
world constitute resistance against the
tithes of banal evil the rise of
campaigns for social justice
Environmental Conservation transparency
in governance and the Inception of new
systems of governance reflects a
collective Awakening to the importance
of vigilance and action in the face of
systemic evil these movements
demonstrate the power of the individual
and Collective conscience not only to
recognize evil but to take a stand
against it disrupting the comfort of
routine where necessary in the end the
answer to why there is still so much
evil in the world is as complex as The
Human Condition itself AR con ccept of
the banality of evil provides a
framework for understanding how ordinary
individuals can become instruments of
harm but it also calls for a deeper
examination of the societies we
construct and the values we espouse I'm
going to repeat again what she wrote
evil comes from a failure to think only
through active and conscious engagement
with the moral dimensions of our
individual and Collective actions can we
hope to illuminate and eventually dispel
the persistent shadow of banal evil in
our
world